we're here tonight to celebrate the
career of a brilliant young man comedian
actor artist magician and some would say
a smooth pimped-out player from the
streets that knows how to get his just
me
please welcome I want you to check this
guide it's very very funny people from
Washington DC and the Grammy goes to
so I bring some names Dave Chappelle
written by Paige
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's all relaxed thanks for coming back
since you guys have been so good to me
tonight I feel like I owe you know this
this next piece is about the real Dave
Chappelle's personal it's actually very
personal but here it is
that was real midnight I was playing
that's a felonious monk song one of my
favorite musicians because his timing
was so ill every comedian is a stickler
for timing and Thelonious Monk was off
time yet perfectly on time you should
study here an aspiring comedian or
inspiring musician he studied I was
going through a real tough time man like
just readjusting and my mom bought me
this time magazine with Bill Cosby on
the cover
Kyle's been inked me and the guy had a
lot of stuff in common like some of the
quotes he would say and I just remember
like after reading that stuff I put it
down
and it was like I'm a big community
every time there's a black celebrity in
trouble Neil's of the beliefs that I
never think he's guilty
and the reason he thinks that it's
because I never think they're guilty
it's just how I roll me at first I
didn't believe it I was like man these
people are obviously trying to destroy
dr. Cosby's rich legacy when Cosby got
sentenced Chappelle and rock called me
back to back
like both of them [ __ ] legitimately
sad I felt bad for them I was explaining
to my younger family members you know
wait like who he was at one point
juxtaposed to what's happening now it's
astounding and I said obviously Bill
Cosby is a hero to me and she doesn't
know what it feels like to think that
your hero might have done something so
heinous all my heroes is even murdered
by the government
registered sex offenders like oh my god
Dave look there's George Washington's
the father of this great nation I'm
gonna go shake his hand I'd be on the
other side like George Washington it's
tough to see your heroes fall let alone
be a villain you like them because he
wrote the Declaration independence and
all that [ __ ] we hold these truths to be
self-evident oh man go get me a sandwich
[ __ ] I'll kill you Liberty justice for
all this is my impression of the
founding fathers of America when the
Constitution was being written hurry up
and finish that Constitution [ __ ] I'm
trying to get some sleep
how many white people there's a tape
screw in a light bulb that is right you
always talk about whatever is close to
your mind it's like the trick lighting
man joke is just something that's
painful to me that you just try to make
funny drugs we started talking about
variety shows we want to do something
that was real personals it was just hurt
I don't know it's just the word personal
kept coming up I started doing drugs
when I was little just like you thought
I grew up in the crack epidemic I tell
jokes about I left the eighties it was
it was not like this in 80s it was like
a crack bomb had gone up like like DC
during the crack epidemic was probably
one of the worst cities in America
everybody I knew sold cracks only God
knows how many people were smoking crack
that made a real big impression over I
see one crackhead trying to break into
somebody's car man then it struck a
chord me I try to stop trying to help
you
I want the [ __ ] stop and now there's a
opioid epidemic are they treating the
opioid epidemic the way that they
treated the crack epidemic no this is a
national health emergency well we were
coming up with police by the National
Guard addicts were criminals she was
like a little suspicious a little
suspicious every dead black person the
police found as crack sprinkled all over
these white folks look exactly like us
during the crack it so now that your
community is getting destroyed is the
whole nother ballgame
there's a huge window of empathy y'all
wanna party what up here comes a
deep-water
this is [ __ ] I shouldn't even say to
the [ __ ] it's not politically correct to
say these things I'm gonna say something
that I'm not allowed to say I know it
sounds [ __ ] up I'm not supposed to say
today I'm gonna get canceled for sure I
don't think people pay money to see a
guy speak precisely and carefully most
other you have a responsibility to speak
recklessly he's a comedian who's kind of
trying to jab the lion you know who's
trying to test the water way back on the
second episode I did this piece about
the a crack addict coming to a hey Drug
Awareness Week at a school I got a lot
of complaints about it I got a lot of
letters about a lot of people said I was
insensitive so I brought them back again
to the show if you say to a comedian you
can't do this
I guarantee you they will immediately do
it
against two of Chicago's finest MC you
give it up for common and Kanye West I
walked in the crib I've got two kids and
my baby mama late Oh
comedians and musicians were like this
every comic wants to be a musician
every musician banks they're funny it's
a very strange relationship isn't it all
these people we all have in common I
think we all have very personal message
that they try to get across
first of all I've known Dave for a long
time he's a genius he's a real comedy
genius I think that the angley's seen
things flow is about Betty see and all
this [ __ ] they talk about all the news
about how divided the nation is going I
love them I support and if you at home
washing machine on Netflix remember
[ __ ] you clicked on my face I don't
have to agree with everything that he
says I just trust me was the person that
went take the Haitians say all that [ __ ]
but I for one find solace in the arts I
don't have to agree with all the art
consumed but it helps me understand how
I actually feel about it at 19 champion
is the youngest comedian to ever appear
on Star Search he's from Washington DC
here's Dave Chappelle
[Applause]
thank you guys very much like when I'm
on stage I get real happy up there like
maybe that's the only time in my adult
life that I feel like myself standing up
there you know I mean like a gladiator
and their mics is on him and you look
down and everyone's looking at what you
are and it's all of these smiles around
you and they get dressed
they put perfume all this stuff and
they're going to see your show it's the
best feeling man I love stamping that's
why I love my art form because I
understand every practitioner of it
whether I agree with them or not
I know where they're coming from they
want to be heard they got something to
say there's something they noticed they
just want to be understood love this job
it saved my life these people are at
least as influential to me as my family
we fight and we fuss and we have jealous
of each other we get mad at each other
but my life wouldn't been what it was
without each and every one of them and I
consider them my family with them it was
way bigger the hit Bob that's like kind
of like that was our work those my
[ __ ] write down what this was like
this so nothing that will come between
you're watching us I appreciate that
just now I want you to know [ __ ]
everybody Dave Chappelle understand it's
always a really gratifying experience
making these videos that take a more
documentarian look at a single artist
whether it's Chappelle Quentin Tarantino
or Bo Burnham delving into an artist
body of work always provides a window
into their soul it's also why I love
dantana Leaders class creating a modern
cinematic documentary with soul it's an
invaluable guide to crafting a story out
of someone's life experience for me it
alone made my Skillshare membership
worth it skill shares catalog of
thousands of classes in film business
technology and more make being a member
a no-brainer no matter what your
interests are but see for yourself right
now you can get two months of Skillshare
for free with our link click the link in
the description and get two months of
unlimited access to thousands of classes
for free plus it helps us to at no cost
to you and as always thanks to our
patrons who make this channel possible
thanks for watching